第一回、臭いで当てられないもの選手権！！！
は）よおおおおお！！！！
は）よぉおおおおお！！！
は）はい、という訳でこちらの企画はですね
は）各自、臭いで分かりづらいもの
は）事前に準備してもらいました。
は）持ってきてますね？
た）バッチリ。　ま）ハイ。
は）色んな臭いがあると思うんですけども
は）やっぱ...分かりやすいじゃない？
は）臭いって。
は）臭いかいだら....
は）あ〜...これはち◯こだなと。
は）あ〜これは....
は）う◯こだなと。
ま）小学生かっ///
は）臭いって特徴的には分かりやすいと思うんですけども
は）その中でもこの三人が各々考えた、
は）これは臭いをかいだだけでは分からないであろう
は）臭いのあるものをちょっと準備してもらって、
は）各自持ってきてもらって、
は）それが（それを）残りの二人で当てるという。
は）簡単なゲーム。
た）俺自信あるよ。
は）僕も中々...難しいと思いますよ。
ま）俺はぁそんなにかなあ...ww
は）ちょww　ま）あははwww
ま）えなんか特徴的だけど〜w
は）かっ..あっじゃあ勝った人から順番決めるのにしよう。
は）最初はぐっ...
は）待って。挨拶してなくね？
こんにちわあああ！！！＠△＄＆＊！！！
は）じゃんけんぽいっ！
は）しょっ！
は）あっ.....
は）二番手！
た）おぉ〜　ま）無難なの選んだじゃん！（？）
た）じゃんけんぽんっ！
た）しょっ！しょっ！
ま）一番で！
は）一番！
は）じゃあ１(まさき )２(はじめ)３(たくみ)の順番で
は）じゃあまさきさん準備の方をよろしくお願いします！
ま）はい！
は）出題者以外の、こっち二人がいるんで
は）一番当てた数が多かった人が、勝者という。
ま）はい、これで〜す
は）もう？？もう？もう？　ま）うん。近づけてる。
は）もう？もう？？待って！
は）あ、いい臭いだ。
は）えぇっ...あぁ　んなあぁあ
は）うわぁなんか...むずいなぁ！た）まじ？　は）まじ
ま）いくよぉ？たくみさん。
た）うん、いいよ。
は）良い臭いじゃね？
た）あ、良い臭いする
た）あ〜分かった！
は）分かった！？
た）分かった。
ま）あはは↑↑
た）分かったよこれきたわ
ま）これが身近な人はすぐわかると思う。
ま）じゃあ、答えてもらいま〜す。
ま）せ〜の！！
た）スティックのり！　　は）金木犀!
ま）wwww
ま）たくみさん正解で〜〜す！！
た）イエェェェエエ！！
は）あーなるほどね〜〜
ま）なんか、臭いは特徴的だけど〜
ま）目閉じてると意外と.....
ま）わかんな....
は）そこらへんのフルーツ持ってきたのかと思ったよw
ま）あははwww
ま）はじめ何て言ったっけ？w
金木犀ｗ
wwwwwwww
は）二問目〜私が選んだのはこちらでございます。
は）まあまあいたって普通だとは思うんですけども
た）絶対嘘じゃん！
は）でも結構...でもあるよよく。
ま）クサイ系ではない？
は）いやそれはまぁ人によりけりだと思うね。
は）ホント！？　ま）え〜なになに...
た）分かったこれ！！
は）ハイ。
ま）わ〜なにこれ！
ま）えぇ〜〜〜全然わかんない！
ま）えぇ〜〜↑なにィ↑全然わかんない！
ま）ウエァエッへッヘェェエ！
は）では正解を...聞きましょう。
は）いっせーのーでで行きますよ？
た）はい。
は）せ〜の！
た）スーパーカップバニラ味の　　ま）放置されたスーパーカップ
wwwwwwwww
た）成れ果て...
＼ﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟｰﾝ!!／
た）うわぁっ！　ま）あはははwwwww
は）なんで！なんで分かったぁ？？
ま）これ絶対...@＊＄％＃
た）もお〜これで...うわぁあって!!（？）
は）なんで？なんで分かった？？
た）何週間も置いてあるじゃん！
は）.......ッッぁっ.....
ま）ッッゥオエ！！
た）ウフゥウ！！
は）待って待って待ってwwwwwww
は）はい、というわけで
は）1ポイント(まさき)２ポイント(たくみ)になりました！！
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
ま）イエイ！
た）これはじめが失敗したら....
た）あ、そうださっき失敗した....
は）も、もう勝ち目ないじゃん。
＼ｺッ...／
ま）えっなに怖い怖い
は）え、こわこわ
は）じゃ、僕から行きます　僕から行きます
た）え待って待って待ってまだ..まだ準備が...
は）まだ準備！？
ま）準備ってなに
ま）ね、なんかヤバイ音してるよ  は）ｺﾝｺﾝｺﾝｺﾝ
は）出ない！？　ま）何何出ないってなに！
ま）わかんないよぉ
は）えぇっ！ま）エエーーー！？
は）どういうリアクション！？　ま）どういうこと！？？
は）もう、近い？
た）近いです
は）嗅ぎます！　た）はい。
ま）エッ、クサイのォォーー♂！？！？
は）なにこれ？
は）あ〜なんか...
は）なんかす...なんだろう....
ま）吐いちゃう？吐いちゃう？
は）いや、何だろな....割とねー
ま）wwwっ
ま）体育館シリーズで来てる？
た）あ〜、ちょっと一回豆腐（？）
た）体育館ぽいらしいっすね〜
ま）エッ？
ま）エヘヘヘヘェwww
は）体育館ぽいでしょ？
ま）いや体育館だねこれ完全にwww
は）...あっ！
は）ねえ〜〜...
た）あ、これちょっと落ちにくい..
は）ええっ！？
ま）エエッッ！？
は）ちょっとまってww　た）うそうそうそw
は）全然なんか
は）こういう感じなのかなっていうのは分かった
ま）うん。
は）整った？
ま）整いました。
た）じゃあ行きます！
た）せ〜の！
ま）グローブ　　は）体育館シューズ
た）あ〜全然違うわ〜
は）えぇっ？
た）グローブでも体育館シューズでもないっすよねえ
た）開けてください！
た）オープン！
は）何これー？
た）これは〜...
た）昔〜、今から７年ほど前に死んだおじいちゃんが
た）その前さらに２０年くらい前に使っていた
た）ヘアーワックスの成れの果てです...
あはははwwww
＼ﾌﾟｼｭｰｰｰ／
は）はい、はい！！＼ﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟｰﾝ／
は）はい、はいはい！
は）いいですか？
は）アックスのクリックでしょ？
た）大正解！！イエーーイ！
は）おっしゃーー！！イエーーイ
た）クリックだね。
は）クリックでしょ？
ま）何で分かんだよおかしくない？w